عيون العائلات تراقب بدقه كل تفصيل على
نشرات الاخبار علها تلمح وجوه ابراهيم
وزوجته واولاده الثلاثه بين الناجين مع كل
عمليه انقاذ يشاهدونها على الشاشات
يعني
انا شجعته ايه والله
ويا ريت ما سجلته
بس اسمع هيك بيقمت قلبي بصير
الوقت قبل ساعات من الزلزال كان حديث
هاتفي مطول بين ابراهيم ووالدته
اكثر من ثلاث ارباع ساعه احكي معه وصار
يحكي لي على الوضع هونيك هو مبسوط صارت
بالليل طلع الزلزال اجيت اتصلت
الوضع الاقتصادي المتدهور في لبنان هو ما
دفع بهذه العائله الى الهجره قبل حوالي
اربعه اشهر تواصلنا مع الخارجيه حتى اليوم
رجعنا تواصلنا معهم مره ثانيه اخذوا
اللوكيشن البيت تبعه
والاسم المنطقه واخذوا اسمائهم والصور
وقالوا لنا خليكم عالسما انه ان شاء الله
يكون حس على بدايه الزلزال انه قدر طلع من
البيت كونه البيت كتير صغير يعني
يعني الخروج منا بيكون سهل كتير فبنتمنى
انه يكون حس على الزلزال وطلع لبره هو
المنشور الاخير الذي نشرته العائله
المفقوده على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي قبل
يوم واحد من الزلزال وتضرعات العائله بان
يتبعه منشور اخر يزف سلمتهم